jay-z's message for Kanye West Lindsay
Lohan is back dition on dating and the
future of Mean Girls and what with the
guise of psyche
hey guys Denny here now as the year
comes to an end
there is one fairytale ending we all
need and that's for jay-z and Kanye to
end their beat can I get an amen
no okay cool well we might be one step
closer to amends after the drama that
followed Kanye calling out Jay on stage
during his st. Pablo tour jay-z had said
the fact that Jay brought up Beyonce and
Blue Ivy in that on stage ranch was not
cool but it appears home may be in the
holiday spirit because during a stop in
Yeezys hometown of Chicago Jay had a
message for Kanye
[Music]
[Applause]
soon
you
[Applause]
you cheated
[Applause]
you guys hear that piece of love he also
sent praise to chance the rapper so
clearly you was filling the shy town
love but the shoutout to Kanye seemed
pretty damn heartfelt so here's
hopefully we get a watch the throne
reunion I keep saying it I'm putting out
in the universe I mean while someone who
might be staging a comeback of her own
miss Lindsay Lohan lilo made a rare
public appearance last night at the
Daily Mail holiday party in New York
last night now in case you didn't know
Lindsay has been living her best live in
Dubai but is she ready to make movies
again specifically a mean-girl sequel I
in a game for this I'm here in New York
so Tina Fey better be hiding or I'm
gonna find her and learn Michael's I
know where his desk is what would Cady
heron be up to right I'm thinking she's
she's been living in Africa and adopts
her children very Madonna
so she's game for another Mean Girls but
lilo did also tell us she has several
other projects in the works overseas
plus she's loving being away from the
cameras in the Middle East
and can you blame her Lindsay's private
life became a hot topic once again this
week when rumors surfaced she was dating
a bodybuilder who calls himself the
Korean Hulk but she cleared that up real
fast that's not what's on the registry
what is your what is your level at this
time
I don't think anyone could even be
ineligible because I'm never there all
the time
no I have good friends and good family
and I'm happy with myself but one day do
you wanna have a family yeah course they
do but I'm focused on I want to focus on
what I what I really feel I want to do
right now I think that's important good
for you and Linz you guys give us a shot
if you're ready for a little Lindsay
Lohan come back all right well two guys
who are back in action themselves
Dule Hill and James Roday the fellas are
reap rising their roles as psychic
detective Shawn and Gus for psych the
movie the to reunite with the rest of
the gang in the upcoming holiday movie
to match wits with the vengeful thin
white duke played by the hilarious
Zachary Levi the guy shared their
favorite lines from the long-running TV
series with our Leigh Ann Aguilera and
fun bonus dule also revealed which she's
all that castmates he still keeps in
touch with but has there ever been a
line that really stuck with you Maggie
character Juliet set a line I'm dodging
the question and shipping it was I think
it was in the first yin yang episode at
the movie theater at the end when we
caught her and then I'm supposed to go
on a date with Rachel's character and
Juliet finally steps up finally it was
like okay why don't we normally get some
popcorn and watch a movie and Shawn she
says something along the lines of like
the best things the richest things
aren't supposed to come easy no I always
sort of stuck with me yeah yeah another
one kisses in in life is another one is
yeah just could you put a delay are you
still in touch with your she's all that
co-stars and what's your favorite memory
of Paul Walker
oh I am still in touch with uh a good
portion mmm Gabrielle Union Freddie
Prinze jr. I guess that's not really a
good portion and that's change but
that's too but I um I stay in touch with
him all the time I was just texting me
Freddie the other day my favorite memory
of Paul Walker was on driving down we
were driving down went towards his years
ago and I'm driving down the toward I
just pulled up next to him and even
realize like he didn't realize it was me
next to him I roll down the window
I'm on driving he's like you like just
driving he could tell someone's looking
at him but he's not really trying to you
never try to give me the energy and I
when I pulled up and I'll back up and I
pull up again just grilling him like
this then I found that to me like five
minutes mine looked over he's like you
don't mean Paul was a good dude do I
really I thought it was a no he's had a
great time working with them you guys
can catch dule and James and psyched the
movie which premieres tonight on the USA
Network alright guys that's it for today
my friends but be sure you're subscribed
to our channel and turn your
notifications on because tomorrow is new
music Friday also have another holiday
party tonight so wish me luck